it's almost time to hit the road but
before we do it's time for of all shows
the doggy dog
that's right we like to leave you with a
little something to go there he goes and
we can't talk pets without talking about
my other burning passions
sorry ross afternoon removal
so sorry it smells good though it smells
so good yeah sorry to me to squeeze it
on you um okay all pet owners know our
furry family members that we love like
to leave us little surprises to find
later and um this is where this comes in
this is angry orange pet odor eliminator
spray and it smells so good it's an
enzymatic cleanser
that works on fabrics and hard surfaces
you name it and it's totally non-toxic
for kids and pets which is so great and
it smells like fresh oranges okay and my
dogs are getting up there in age selena
has diabetes she's had a little she's
had a few accidents i'll just say that
i'd rather smell this you know
thank you thank you
yeah absolutely
um
yeah
i just got brand new carpet the other
day and i was so proud
and one of the dogs just peed all over
and i was just like not even a day
[Laughter]
but i love them i know
so much anyway
thank you so much
out to all the guests in the audience
home and on the go we're so honored that
you take the time to spend it with us
this is all for you and about you have a
wonderful day and we hope we get to see
you soon
[Music]